Đấy là mang hình quảng gáo trong tháng máy đồng tiền trên thế giới vào đồng những năm 2018,
yết ai biết rằng chính trích mang hình nhỏ này đã bởi giá cả bụng ngành chuyển thương khoảng tận mới,
và đến sau tất cả chính là Focus Media, quanh gục về 2-3 chiếc khoảng cáo chuyển hình đang ở thời gian hỏng game,
chỉ có ông gia năm sôn là đặt giám một câu hỏi khoảng tận khác.
Ngài TV còn nơi nào khi con người gần như buộc phán yên, và ông đã truyết tới tháng máy.
Một công giản hết kiến, và có tận sốt tiếp súc cực cao cũng không giống như TV, nơi người xem có thể chín cách bất cứ lúc nào.
Ở đó, mang hình quảng cáo tháng máy ký tật số đồng tiền trên thế giới được ra đời vào năm 2018,
cùng với tốc độ đối thi hoa, Focus Media vẫn vảng chếm được một phán quan trọng trong thị trường quảng cáo.
Tuy nhiên, khi ra hội bước vào kiến miến số, người dùng quá đồng quên với video trên lật cao trên internet và smartphone.
Giải đoạn năm 2018 đến năm 2018, mang hình tiếp tục được nân cấp lên mang hình áp đây,
mang lại trải nghiệm xác nét hơn, cùng âm tháng xung đậu để thống kịp thoại quan xe em lỗi dung của người dung,
nhưng công nghệ không chỉ dừng ở trước lợi hiện thi, năm 2018, Focus Media giảm át mắt mang hình LCD với tiếp kiến máy kếm hình kếm,
cho phép thực hiệu trên phát nhiều nỗi dung của bước theo các hình tức khác nhau.
Và đến năm 2018, tận bộ mặt lưới tiếp tục bước ra kiến miến thuân mình với khả năng quảng lý thử ra và đồng bộ dữ liệu khi bước sang giải đoạn
hình không trọng hay mi ba đến 2018, sáng 2018, sáng buôn đã thay đổi hoàn toàn thỏi quên thi ra của người dung.
Focus Media tiếp tục thay đổi với tiếp kiến trạng viện hiện đại hơn và tối uống trạng điện thi như chính trách điện thoại mà chúng ta cập bối ngại.
Đồng thời tiếp hợp năm gờ và NFC đến mặt hình tự nơi hình thi quảng cao thành một điện trạng từng tạng.
Chỉ cần một cú trạng điện thoại và có thể mở website nhạc yêu đại hay mùa hàng ngày lập tức.
Tạo cái nối lên mặt dưới mùa hàng ngoại tuyền và mùa hàng sâu, giúp thân giấu dự nắng quảng cao từ chú ý tương ta đến chuyển đồ.